you
make I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm the
one I'm okay all right good morning good
afternoon good evening whatever part of
the world you're in this is episode 316
home team lots of stories lots of things
going on uh it's been I don't know 4
days since we did our last podcast three
days since we did our last podcast and
it seems like it's been a couple weeks
because of uh the events taking place uh
I'll share with you some of the stories
we're going to go in uh when when the
weekend comes by and you hear quotes
like this
Ray Dalo there's a there's now a 50%
chance of World War as the Israel Hamas
conflict threat threatens to spread Ray
doio just said this by the way on
October 13th Jamie Diamond says this is
the most dangerous the world's been in
decades okay uh we'll cover that Egypt
can save gaza's civilians Wall Street
Journal Story how come they don't take
them in then Forbes does a story on our
podcast last week with Charlie Kirk
we'll share that and you'll see how
quick the next story after they said
what they said about the podcast that we
did how they contradicted themselves
Vinnie you got some thoughts on that
yeah a lot of people are saying there's
a civil war going on the Republican
Party within Congress within Ben Shapiro
against Tucker within Candace against
Megan Kelly is it really a civil war is
it just the exchange of ideas
differences is that okay we'll talk
about that uh even on the left you know
the Democratic Socialist supportive of
Gaza supportive of not Gaza but
Hamas it's it's it's a bit of a a
conflicting on that side as well on the
Democratic side we'll cover that a lot
of billionaires are removing money from
paying
to IV League schools condemning the fact
that they haven't yet to condemn Hamas
and uh it's challenging to the point
where one of the professors from Cornell
University if you haven't seen this
we'll show you this clip very very
disturbing clip from a professor
celebrating almost of what's going on
there saying the attacks uh uh uh the
Hamas Terror attacks are EX erating and
exciting disturbing to say the least and
then outside of that we got some
business stories to cover Arnold Schwarz
Ando blast Democrats saying they want to
f up every city in America as if he
wasn't supportive of that just two three
years ago but we'll address that as well
Jada Pink's new book uh got Will Smith
responding we got some thoughts and
ideas we can process that uh us EAS
sanctions on Venezuelan oil for free
your presidential election this is
something that some people might say at
this point you want to talk about oil
but you'll see the way Tom will break it
down why this is a very important story
having to do with lithium with Exxon and
a bunch of other oil stories put
together we'll talk recession we'll talk
why LinkedIn is laying off 700 employees
and Austin's office Market is exploding
yet no one is moving in and then some
home home sales numbers and then Mexican
calois cartel's message to members stop
making fentol or die this is a Wall
Street Journal story and last but not
least nearly 70% of active service
members are overweight report finds I'm
sure that is very intimidating to our
enemies to see us our military being
overweight okay so having said that um
right off the bat I said we go into the
Ray doio and Jamie Diamond story uh Rob
if you want to kind of pull that up go
to page four by the way folks if you're
listening to this our notes today are 30
pages I keep getting messages about
people saying Pat we'd love to get the
notes we'd love to get the notes we'd
love to get the notes here's what we're
probably going to be doing on our on our
website vt.com in the next 2 to six
weeks we're going to have a membership
where those who pay whatever the amount
is going to be $9.99 or $14.99 whatever
the dollar amount is going to be we will
give you the notes so you'll be able to
print out the notes from all the podcast
and follow us while we're doing this but
it's only members only if that's
something you're interested in you may
want to text the word podcast to
31034 11132 again text the word podcast
to 31034 11132 and you'll get the
breakdown on all the notes that we get
for podcast preps and you'll follow it
with us again podcast text award to 310
340 11132 okay there's now a 50% chance
of World War I as the Israel Hamas
conflict threatens to spread hedge fund
Legend Ray Dalo this is a 20 billion man
says this is again Insider
story so uh uh this may be the most
dangerous time the world has seen in
decades Jamie Diamond says if you can
pull up his Instagram so people can see
this as well hch fun Legend Ray do
believes that the risk of transitioning
from contained conflict to an
uncontained hot world has risen from 35%
to 50% over the last 2 years stating in
my opinion this war has a high risk of
leading to several other conflicts of
different stating of different types in
a number of places and it is likely to
have harmful effects that will extend
beyond those in Israel and Gaza Dalia
who is known for his expertise in global
power shifts and historical Cycles
seized the Israel Hamas and Russia ukra
conflicts as brutal struggles likely to
persist until one side emerges as the
clear Victor and he warns if they spread
to other countries most importantly the
major countries there will be a much
more horrific uh uh hot World War Tom
what are your thoughts on what Dalo is
saying here as well as Jamie Diamond
well but Dalo and Jamie Diamond don't
want anything happen to the US Equity
markets that's what they're very very
concerned about is is US asset prices us
Equity markets so they're sounding the
alarm on one thing and what it is is the
escalation and when you look at the
chessboard there it is that's Jamie Dam
this this may be the most dangerous time
in the world has seen in decades go
ahead Tom yeah so what is he worried
about this is what he worried about you
you got to look five moves ahead and
there's a nice man that wrote a book
your next five moves think about the
next moves here and the one that
everybody's worried about as you were
seeing it over the weekend was Iran
everybody all the ambassadors were going
to talk to Iran they're saying hey baby
stay in your corner stay in your corner
don't you we know what you're trying to
do over there in in Syria don't show up
with arms don't show up with support
stay out of this and there is a lot of
work and that is what everyone is
worried about the escalation of the
conflict is not the Saudis it's not the
Egyptians the Egyptians are not armed
and the Saudis are not interested in
getting into full conflict it is Iran
and Syria making it a two-front war that
destabilizes energy which will have a
domino effect so you have leading
economic thinkers
Doo and Diamond saying we don't want to
see this escalate and you can translate
it down to one sentence we don't want
Iran to get with Syria make it a twoof
front war and make it a regional
conflict which affect nearly a World War
because of what it's going to do to the
markets yeah I think uh it begs the
question uh what would the current state
of the world look like under the
presidency of Donald Trump yep right so
uh if you look at the odds don't go soft
on me Adam yeah exactly so if you look
at the the the odds that Jamie Diamond
is throwing out there right um and Ray
Delio for that matter basically going
from 35% to 50% to a World War I I think
uh it begs the question what would have
happened under Donald Trump yes that's
me saying this yeah um you know Trump
came into office in 2016 like a bull in
a china shop obviously the media was
against him and you know he Al obviously
played a part in that as well
temperatures flared up uh he came in
like a bowl in a china shop but the
whole reason the whole premise that Joe
Biden was elected not because he was a
strong capable vibrant leader is just
because he just wasn't Donald Trump
anyone could have beat Donald Trump just
because of the the the cards that were
stacked against him but uh I think it's
uh incumbent on all of us to
ask how much different would this be
under Donald Trump are you going to tell
us are you going to repeat that three
times so would it be I want to hear your
point but the point is the the the
resounding narrative from the people on
the right is basically it not under
Trump there was no there was no world
wars under Trump there were no Wars
under Trump what do you think I think
it's a I think it's a definite question
that should be raised and a lot of
people on the left don't want to hear
that question be raised what do you
think you just narrated it what I think
if you just look at the numbers there's
something to be said there now we don't
know for sure if Ukraine would have been
invaded by Russia we don't 100% know
that we don't know if this would have
happened under Trump I think it's a very
imp comparative question to ask though
and oh my God Adam it's so so okay I got
you so Rob why don't you do this do you
want me to say that I guarantee no it's
not you said the same thing five times I
got it then make your point Rob do me a
favor and pull up the clip by shamat and
let's play what shamat said and he's
actually given perspective like I want
to hear your thoughts if you're saying
that I want you to tell me your follow
through with here's what I'm thinking
instead of it begs to question here's
what shamat says with his opinion and
then we judge it or we tear it apart
play the shamat CP go for it this is the
All In please let him let us go back to
the clip and let's play it go ahead when
Trump was elected I was told that it was
the end of the world and that's what I
thought and I'd already underwritten him
as an F okay and then four years into
the presidency he was probably like
a c in my mind and then as I get a
little bit of distance away I realized
no hold on a second this guy was like a
BB Plus like he was pretty good I voted
for Hillary Clinton I voted for Joe
Biden but this is Theon can you pause
that he voted for Hillary and he voted
for Joe Biden he was a former owner of
the Golden State Warriors I think he
made his first billion uh from Facebook
Tom if I'm not mistaken this is not a
trump guy keep playing I did for the
things that he was supposed to do a good
job and for where every other president
found a way to frankly make our
situation a little bit worse
specifically around Wars he did not do
that and that is a huge accomplishment
that I think needs to be acknowledged I
think the thing that was smart about
Trump David he was Will to do business
David going to negotiate he feel David
saxs is uh Elon musk's right-hand guy oh
wow David saaks is a guy that's
probably according to what you read
about one of elon's 10 guys he trusts to
process issues with It's s that's the
guy what's like he was the guy when
Ronda santis announced his candidacy on
X via Twitter it was David saaks that
was actually doing the interview along
with Elon he's a guy a no he's a
respected guy keep going feel the need
to make these moral condemnations all
the time he was willing to meet with Kim
Jong-un and he was willing to meet with
Putin and and Si ping and he avoided uh
criticizing them personally he didn't
call them dictators he talked about how
smart they are yeah it's the art of the
deal right I mean at the end of the day
he's looking to do
business okay so what are your thoughts
on that Tom when you hear shamad here
well yeah I tell you what I tell you
what I think I think you've got Silicon
Valley thinkers there that are backing
up against the backdrop of of of caling
number one they've calmed down since
Trump number two they back they have a
backdrop to step back and number three
now they have a little bit of history
and a little bit of um perspective in
terms of what's Happening Now versus
then and they're getting back to it and
saying I go from being a Hillary voter
to seeing perspective and honestly
saying you know what I should have
gotten this a bigger race I should have
given this a much bigger raise in my you
know rating than I did and I think that
is probably on the mind of more people
than want to admit it so let me ask this
question let me ask this question of all
of you here so it it is this crisis in
Israel okay and Hamas obviously tragic
worse since the
Holocaust we've all seen the videos
we're following the story closely is
this helping Trump or is this helping
Biden okay you know especially with
Biden's 60 Minutes Or you know even in
the 60 minutes when the 60-minute
interviewer says you know even though
the president seemed so tired he felt
this was so important for him to do this
it's as if 60 Minutes is defending how
tired the president is right but is this
helping Biden okay for him to stand
firmly on Israel and backing them up is
this helping Trump that the numbers
change at all what do you think how this
is helping out let me go to Adam first
Adam well well uh I think in an odds
perspective this is helping Trump this
is my point so the whole thing that
shamas said is that it was marketed as
an F he said that right he underwritten
Trump's presidency as an F A lot of
people did that was essentially my point
and then as time went on time heals all
wounds as they say it went from an F to
a d to a c to a final grade of a bb+ and
I think it's you know people come around
in all different time everyone has their
own time Horizon for when they come
around to these types of Notions so at
the end of the day I think this is only
going to help Trump and you know Biden
he's standing strong apparently he's
saying the right things apparently he's
going to go visit Israel saw this week
but at the end of the day I think this
does help Trump I first of all Pat it's
that same media that's trying to make
Biden look like he's strong and he's
it's the same media that told us that he
was this evil war war II Maniac that was
going to get us all messed up and like I
think it's time for us to get pissed off
Pat because that that same media that
ignored all it and tried to make us
think that it was him now guess what we
told you so and now it's real now we're
on the when people were saying that
we're on the brink of World War II with
uh North Korea and everything now it's
actually in your faces we told you we
told you that it was all Bs and now it's
actually happening we are literally on
the brink of it and it's like you can't
say I can't point at them like we told
you so but like we were right I think
it's helping Trump for one simple reason
everybody doesn't like pitbulls oh I
don't like pitbulls they're they're
they're dangerous around kids and you
can't predict them and then five houses
on the Block get broken into and
everybody wants a pitbull that is the
perspective that has come to America and
I'll break it down just that simple and
if you think I'm oversimplifying it
sorry I think this is helping Trump and
the fact they don't even talk about
Biden is is is deafening silence and Pat
I like the analogy you used about the
mafia boss would you I don't know if you
want to unpack that again in this regard
which one is that well you said
basically you know when when the mafia
leader is strong everyone kind of yeah
chills whereas whereas the mafia boss is
sort of weaker uh that's where chaos
ensues yeah again this is a um this is
a that's the part about when it's peace
time everybody hates a wartime leader
like Trump okay everybody hates not
everybody 80% hates a wartime leader
like Trump because the brain is not
consumed with war anxiety and stress so
you're like dude you're so annoying
Trump stop like oh my God everything's
not a war you don't need to fight
everybody relax why are you like this
dude everything is
peaceful and then when it's war time
everybody is scared shitless of having a
peacetime leader yeah and that's what's
going on right now Biden is not a
wartime leader he's a peacetime leader
he's a guy that's everything is peaceful
you come in at 9:00 you leave at 2:00 in
the afternoon nobody can tell it's okay
you're a peacetime guy you don't work
that hard you don't you're not always on
the screen you're not always talking
good I don't have to see this guy like
billbo almost said you know I kind of
prefer My Presidents to only see them
once every six months like my
mother-in-law I don't you or some of the
girlfriends that you don't like I don't
want to see her too often I kind of feel
like that's the kind of President we
have right now but when it's wartime you
know everybody misses their wartime
leader you know who misses their wartime
leader even the people that hated the
wartime leader yeah and that's the most
interesting Dynamic to see that
just stand up piece of
but you know what we kind of need him
right now dog yeah we kind of need him
right now hey Chamberlain yeah what's up
you're not a wartime leader bro you got
to go knock on the door and call that
guy you hate the most I'm not calling
him you got to call him you're the only
guy that he's willing to listen to to
come back you got to go beg him to come
because he's the only guy that can go up
against this guy named Adolf I'm not
going to go after him he's a piece of
you're the only guy that he's has to
hear it from the only person that can
make him come back is you you better do
it to save this country you better do it
to save the world hey you uh Winston I
can't stand you but we need you back as
a prime minister what do you say we need
you back as a prime minister say it one
more time yeah we need you back as a
prime minister who's your Daddy yeah
you're you're my daddy okay I'll come
back then Churchill comes back and he
fights and wins the war and all of us
now speak English instead of speaking
German okay that's exactly right there's
an element of this taking place today
that people are paying attention to but
I want to kind of get your feedback on
this Adam cuz I know
the last couple weeks you you've given
your Insight on what's going on here and
it's been very interesting on talking
what's going on with Israel especially
since you were there just a couple
months ago so how do you react when you
see okay a professor okay a professor
who rob Cornell University Professor
calls Hamas Terror attacks exhilarating
and exciting okay this is Cornell
University we have a friend here that
went to Cornell uh dink uh uh uh this is
a New York Post story Cornell you know
matter of fact before I even say it
because people are like well you know
how do you know this is the truth let's
just play the clip and let's let you
hear what this professor at Cornell said
Rob if you can make this bigger it's 24
seconds go and play this clip it was
exera it was inera it
was if they weren't
inera by this this challenge to the
Monopoly of VI by this ship
they would human
iated stand with palestin and the you
see on occupation whatever it says to
the right let me finish up the story
Cornell professor uh Russell rickford
spark controversy with comments made
during a prop Palestine rally he
described Hamas recent Terror on Israel
which caused over 14400 casualties as
exhilarating and energizing asserting
that it had shifted the balance of power
and punctuated Israel's invincibility
illusion rickford speech at the rally
and includeed remarks that it was
exhilarating uh Monopoly of violence the
crowd at the rally join enchanting from
the river of the Sea of Palestine will
be free of slogan deemed anti-semitic by
the American Jews and let me continue
with this because REM remember a lot of
these Ivy League schools are sitting on
10 20 30 4050 and I think Harvard's
sitting on $60 billion of endowment many
of this money has been paid by people
that are pro- Israel and to the point
where billionaires this is a Daily Mail
article drop Ivy leak funding over
failures to condemn Hamas page 11 if you
want to go to it uh
uh ivy league shocks Harvard the
University of Pennsylvania face a
potential loss of $487 million in
funding from prominent donors with Drew
support billionaire King Griffin who
pledged $300 million to Harvard
criticized the university stance on
Hamas while the Wexner Foundation which
donated 56 million over 30 years would
your support expressing being stunned
and sickened Israel billionaire Idan
offer and his wife batia who donated $20
million to Harvard resigned from an
executive board hedge fund manager Bill
Amman who donated 17 million to Harvard
said he want hire students involved
Apollo Mark Rowan called for donors to
the University of Pennsylvania to either
withdraw funding or send a dollar in
protest former US ambassador John
Huntsman Jr whose family donated 5050
million dollars to upen by the way John
Huntsman Jr was a former president
presidential candidate vowed to Halt the
future donation citing youens silence on
Hamas Adam when you see these stories
when you hear things being said how do
you react so yeah I've been going deep
down the rabbit hole of understanding
the the sympathy for Hamas but
specifically in America right and I came
across this article I mean here's some
numbers for you if you just kind of want
to look at this only four in 10 18 to 29
year olds that's essentially gen Z and
the younger Millennials have a negative
view of Hamas if you just look at the
numbers um overall view 51% so red is
negative green is positive but if you go
by demographics you can see that the
Millennials genx and Boomers it's all 50
plus% negative view of a terrorist
organization called Hamas and if you see
the marketing campaign that BB Netanyahu
is doing and the rest of the democratic
world is doing is that Hamas equals Isis
right yeah but the younger generation
almost a quarter of them does a quarter
only a quarter of them thinks that have
a negative view of them and almost
what's that plus 30 plus% actually have
a positive view of them I'm like I'm
trying to make some sense of this and I
came across this article this opinion
article in a Wall Street Journal and I
kind of want to um reiterate what I
basically found from that but
essentially address this exact issue of
what's going on in modernday Academia so
um essentially the article was um sort
of the title of the article was that
liberals and leftists need a Reckoning
with anti-Semitism and basically it it
tells the story of the reason that Joe
Biden decided to run in 2020 and it
basically dates back to what happened in
2017 in Charlottesville the unite the
right rally and everything that happened
with that where white supremacist drove
his car into people marching and killed
um that one young lady right so if you
recall that that was the famous there
were good people on both sides that
whole speech right so in that in that
protest you know it was tiki torch
carrying almost brown shirt like
Neo-Nazi fascists allegedly um that were
spouting things like Jews will not
replace us so traditionally we've seen
the farri Neo-Nazi KKK be identified
with with sort of that Mantra of of
anti-Semitism and um everything that
comes along with white supremacy but
things have shifted so now it's not as
angry and violent and uh in your face as
it once was now it's sort of taking
place on the beautiful green leafy
campuses of the progressive left whether
that's the Harvard whether it's the
Cornell's whether it's the Berkeley's
it's happening all over this country and
if you just look at the numbers right
there gen Z the progressive Social
Democratic left uh via Academia are
being indoctrinated into this worldview
so uh you have our our youth our college
students focusing on things like
oppression White Privilege uh the hyper
obsession with race identity sexual
orientation and everything that that
applies to what is perceived as power
and the patriarchy and essentially what
comes down to anti-white men so the the
social justice Warriors of America but
here are the two points that they
basically harp on there's two words that
I wasn't really too familiar with but I
was like all right what does these
things mean they talked about
intersectionality and they talked about
decolonization we're all familiar with
America and colonization and imperialism
and all that fun stuff like that so
here's the core ideology of the far-left
progressive woke agenda so
intersectionality that all the victims
of discrimination uh are on the basis of
race sex and sexual orientation are all
interlined it's all so if you're
oppressed you're all interlined into one
common theme okay so the purported
victims of this oppression uh are the
most enthusiastic ironically of uh the
oppression of against the other groups
so for instance if you see the gay
rights if you seen the gays for
Palestine this is the cognitive
dissonance that's going on in the modern
woke Academia left the gays for
Palestine they're holding up signs gays
for Palestine the most ironic part of
that is if you tried to do the Gaze for
Palestine March in Palestine or in the
majority of Middle East countries you
would be executed
You' be stoned You' be hung you beheaded
so good luck doing that in the country
that you are supporting the cognitive
dissonance is alarming to me okay so
that's point one um by the way Israel is
the only country that actually is
totally fine with lgbtq rights when I
was in Israel it was like Tel Aviv was
one of the gayest things I've ever seen
whatever I'm not gay but do your and
this is the same Adam not to C off just
like the Mia Khalifa The porn girl
that's like that's like I Pro Palestine
don't top your head off go be an only
fans porn star while wearing a hijab on
the flag you're go you're dead but in
America so freak and in Democratic
countries you can say whatever you want
to say Point number two is the
decolonization component right so that's
the disposing of the dead white males
throughout history politicians poets
artists authors all that and the
resistance of the oppressed includes
what is an armed struggle to get their
lands and lives back back okay so what
it essentially comes down to is logic is
thrown out the window it's just pure
emotion it's pure rage it's pure
cognitive dissonance and this is what
they're grappling with when you have a
professor basically saying I'm so
enthused by the death of what's
perceived as the oppressors whereas good
luck doing those types of rallies talks
in those types of countries great Point
Tom I I I think it's I think you can
simplify that a little bit and I I I
understand the academic angle there what
you have is if you look at those charts
you've got the youth that are that are
split and it's not liberal extremism
it's Marxism that's mixed in it's deeper
than just oh they're liberals they're
extreme liberals yeah they are extreme
liberals but they're marxists you listen
to AOC it's not extreme uh liberalism
it's Marxism listen to the squad listen
to very carefully and you look at their
grandparents here and by the way it's
much more than 50% Adam it's 75% 64%
there is very negative and then quite
negative so you've got 75% of the Boomer
grandparents you've got 73% of the
Boomer parents and then it moves down in
these two recent Generations that my
friend is a graph showing you what
happens when you move to extreme left
ideology and Marxism on campus you know
that's what's that's what's going on you
know what that tells me you know 18 to
29 23% very negative okay of Hamas 177%
quite negative then you got 60% that
either don't know neither quite positive
or very positive okay who do those 18 to
29 year will spend the most time with
professors colleges MH universities so
guess what what America I love the fact
that these guys are not funding these
universities right now cuz you know what
they're saying they're voting finally
and by the way these are Democrats that
are not voting for giving them money the
only guy here that's a republican that
was King Griffin everybody else was
pretty much on the left you screwed up
my kids and grandkids and you know who
is you know who Wexler is Wexler is the
guy that you know he bought that
building 911 yeah he is connected to the
911 if you really want to find out who
Lex Wexler is go type in Les Wexler 911
and and good luck you'll be distracted
for a couple hours
but you know these guys to say we're not
doing that anymore why because they
realize you send your kids the way you
raise them for 18 years they come back
and they're like dude you're not my kid
what the hell happened to you the last
four years well Daddy they brainwashed
me into thinking you're a you're
an idiot you have no clue what you're
talking about and these are professors
that are sitting there all they want to
do is give you a lip service and there's
no exchange I'm a college professor I
know which I'm talking about here you do
that anyways and P not to cut you off
wait I I I'd be interested to see if God
forbid one of these Hamas people that
are you know coming over through the
Border blow themselves up or some
in front of one of these idiots that has
no idea what the hell is going on see
how see how you feel when it hits home
cuz it's coming I don't care what
anybody says you know it's coming in the
last in the last 72 hours um border has
said that they have found four known
Iranian let's just call them
Troublemaker ter Terror on the terror
watch list so all this all this pro pro
Hamas wait till some blows up in
front of your face and see how your
attitude changes that's not 100%
Mexicans that are trying to flee
terrible terrible things are going INX
Cel call it what it is they're
practically refugees but in the middle
of that it's not 100% people that are
really looking for a better life it's
people taking advantage of the river
humidity to hide inside it and to get
here yeah and exactly and going back
again on this whole everybody from the
left changing their attitude it was all
Trump Mexicans are rapists it's like bro
the Mexicans are going back to Mexico
I've seen videos where they're literally
crying and going back because of how
is over here and it's not it's not
Mexicans it's everybody is coming here
and it it's when the CIA is warning us
of some what's happened to San
Diego you don't blame them they get San
Diego and they say wait a minute where's
all the pictures of the of the yachts
and all the you know yeah Tom I just
want to add one thing to what you said
about the uh the Marxism that's going on
campus Rob would you just Google a
political horseshoe here's one of the
things I've learned definitely since
being at Value tment and understanding
just like just getting smarter getting
more informed trying to understand how
things ex we're used go to IM if you
don't mind
um you you think of political ideology
on the Spectrum that's almost linear so
you have the far left and you have the
far right okay but the the actuality is
that the political spectrum is more like
a horseshoe so where you have the far
left the Socialist Marxist communist uh
authoritarian regimes and then you have
the very far right uh fascist
neonnazi far-right nationalist regimes
that you think that they're
diametrically opposed on their opposite
side of the spectrum but it's not linear
it basically comes into a horseshoe
where they sort of meet in the middle
and it just meets at authoritarian
intolerance and just complete
destruction of whoever does not agree
with your Viewpoint and that's I think
that's something that you someone might
say well why how does the farle
Socialist Marxist on campus identify
with the far right uh Muslim terrorist
organizations it's because the Horseshoe
is what's connecting them because
politically they are not inclined
whatsoever to agree with each other
other than the this is my view and you
will not change my viewpoint and I will
die for this Viewpoint then you make a
really good point and for people that
don't know this go go go study that but
meanwhile keep listening for a second
look how close remember Hitler
suppressed speech and then change as
said Stalin and Stalin made one
newspaper under glass that sat in the
Public Square called the Pravda Pravda
is a Russian word that means truth isn't
that funny that's hilarious and that was
there and then so what do you see AOC
doing we we are using American social
media leaders to cancel conservative
voices we do not want them to be heard
that's AOC that's the squad then go all
the way and look at the history of
fascism and how they suppress speech and
that that horseshoe meets right there
where we can look and see even if you
don't believe in horseshoe Theory just
listen closely did Hitler suppress
speech did Stalin is AOC they eventually
meet and they agree you know what our
opponents need to shut up no no we need
to shut them up correct okay let me read
this next part about Iran uh uh on what
Iran is saying and what US is saying to
Iran so Iran warns uh Israel through un
against ground offensive in Gaza this is
an axio story Iran Iran warned Israel
through un against a ground offensive in
Gaza expressing a desire to avoid
further escalation Iranian foreign
minister Hussein amid Abdullah hian met
with un Eno Envoy Tor wenis land and
stressing Iran's reluctance to see the
conflict turn into a regional war and
expressing a willingness to help release
hostages held by Hamas amid abdan
however indicated that Iran would
respond if Israel pursued a ground
operation in Gaza here we go the
involvement of Iran in the Hamas Israel
conflict could potentially lead to a
broader Regional War the US has
attempted attempted to deter Iran and
its Ally Hezbollah from joining the
fighting and has deployed an aircraft
carrier group and fighter jet to the
region and so so that's the axio story
if they do something and then IR us has
turned
around us warns Iran against escalating
Israel Hamas War into Regional this is
financial time story US President Joe
Biden St sternly cautioned Iran saying
don't don't don't don't when asked about
Iran's potential involvement escalating
the IRA Israel Hamas conflict into
region one he also emphasized the need
for Palestinian State stating Hamas must
be eliminated entirely but there needs
to be a Palestinian Authority and a path
to Pal pal inian State US National
Security adviser Jake solivan conveyed
the existence of a private
Communications with with Iran to deter
escalation highlighting the risk of a
broader conflict and Iran's potential
involvement noting there's a risk of an
escalation of this conflict the opening
of a second front in the north and of
course of Iran's involvement that is a
risk time when you see this okay and you
hear the story where the numbers just
came up to 50% chance of World War III
Ray do was talking about that Jamie
Diamond this the most dangerous we've
had times we've had in decades and now
the fear of Iran telling Israel don't
get involved through un us telling Iran
do not get involved and bring in
Hezbollah how ugly can this thing be or
is it already ugly where there's point
of no return Isn't it interesting that
Pat is reading a story from the
financial times and that is exactly
where the world is running there's three
centers of real Financial strength in
the world one of them is New York one of
them is Hong Kong one of them is London
there's others so you can put it in the
chat and get all upset with me but those
are the anchors and the financial times
is reporting kind of what I was talking
about a little earlier in the podcast is
like they everyone is telling Iran and
by the way Iran is also a source of
energy they're they're an oil producer
and so everyone is like dude you need to
stay in your corner everybody wants to
do everything they can to keep Iran to
stay in its Corner because if Iran if
Hezbollah says we're going to Syria we
need guns and Iran says I'll give you
all you want it's sort of like the way
way we've been giving um Weaponry to
Ukraine we do not want Iran giving
Weaponry to esbah and this is exactly
what Jamie Diamond others are talking
about saying that move on the chess
board is the bad move so we all need to
be talking to Iran take them for coffee
over the weekend get them to calm down
and not step into this thing well Pat
it's almost like we're instigating
though if we if we did that deal for the
hostages and then we just give them you
know $6 billion it's almost like we're
inviting them cuz you know where that
money was going to go there's no hiding
it it's almost like we're pushing them
pushing them pushing them because at the
end of the day don't do this or if you
do this we're going to do this it's
inevitable P to answer the question Tom
at the end it's 100% inevitable
everybody is fighting and if that if you
can't see that it's it's going to be a
World War then you're just you're just
blind bro you're you're blind we're
pushing we want it to happen we we
everybody's put everybody's like um in
Congress they're like you know if Iran
does anything who's that who's that the
congressman Pat that was like Iran we'll
blow up your it's like what are you guys
you're talking about Lindy lindsy Graham
it's like what the hell are you guys
talking about bombing shut up relax
they'll they'll just shut it off they'll
shut it off right now there is a
blockade and the blockade is USS Gerald
Ford we're not there to bomb anything
we're off the coast of Gaza telling
everybody in the rest of the world do
not screw with this situation this is a
blockade do not let anything go in do
not help and so that's what's happening
there the same thing will happen to Iran
we will shut off the Pipelines no one
will be sending tankers into that Gulf
no one that's how you get to Iran you
just shut off the money supply to the
oil now they've got the backdoor money
supply which goes to Russia and the oil
trade and things like that but there
will be a blockade lindsy Graham is just
being too much of the big Warhawk there
need to calm down there's plenty of ways
to step on Iran's uh air hose and if you
don't think that's what's being
discussed over the weekend with
ambassadors you're not paying attention
yeah I think what we've seen over the
last 4 eight 20 years for that matter is
just the polarizing shift whether the
Democrats or the Republicans come in how
to deal with the Quagmire that is Iran
and nobody can speak more about that
than pbd but every four to eight years
all right cool let's give them money
let's let's uh take let's unplug their
nuclear Arsenal all right let's give
them money so they can plug in let's
give them hostages we keep reversing
course on what we're going to do with
Iran and and make no mistake about it
whether it's Hamas whether it's
Hezbollah whether it's the houthi rebels
that's going on in the proxy war that's
in Yemen versus Saudi Arabia Iran is the
tip of the
spirit darur exactly so until we figure
out how we're going to deal with the uh
World nuisance that is Iran where their
greatest exporter for the last since
1979 has been terrorism um we're just
going to keep running to this problem
because we can keep playing whacka all
with Hamas and Hezbollah and all this
but Iran is the situation that needs to
be deal dealt with and make no mistake
about it um the people of Iran Beautiful
People a beautiful
culture as As Good As It Gets uh type of
people you'll find they have no love for
their absolute Theocratic authoritarian
Mula regime if they had the power to rid
themselves of this nuisance they would
do it in a second Unfortunately they
cannot do it exact and that is
essentially the problem by association
and and then it's it's I I think from
Solutions I think there needs to be some
I don't know if it exists I can't I
can't think of one a
bipartisan uh uh Senate intelligence
committee house just put it all together
on the Iran situation and how to deal
with that because it it just keeps
moving and they keep moving the you you
know what scares me a lot I will tell
you what concerns me a lot remember that
one video where these comedians made the
video showing the mom that comes up and
she pulls the uh lgbtq flag and the
teacher reacts and her son is sitting
there and the teacher tells her son shut
up yeah and then you realized these guys
are actors yeah they're and actresses
but that video has gotten a few billion
views online and it's produced a lot of
emotions
okay what percentage of people that
shared that video know it's fake what
percentage of people that shared out of
the two billion people that I watch that
video total what percentage you think no
it's a fake video it's not real it's a
fake video 25 2080 against okay 80% 1.6
billion are convinced that video is real
and It produced emotions okay these deep
fake videos that could come out okay and
what do deep fake videos do that that's
the video right there what do deep fake
videos do deep fake that video right
there what do deep fake videos do deep
fake videos get emotions High it gets
you angry it gets you to hate but most
importantly it gives you permission to
say it's okay for to kill the other
people okay these deep fakes could be
any kind of videos that are out there
okay uh uh both sides could have deep
fake videos to show to validate what
they're doing think about it from CNN
CNN will not show a black man killing a
white person they won't do it CNN won't
highlight the story of a black man
killing a black man but CNN will show a
white man killing a black man for 24/7
for weeks until they get so much anger
In Their audience to
react to it right Jesse small did you
see that these two black mega people
came in like oh now that it's a
fake story oh so the next story a cat
got on a fight with a dog and there was
racism involved in this fight between a
cat and a dog because the cat was black
and the white the dog was a white poodle
genocide those dogs are trying to
eliminate the cats but but here's the
part that we we as viewers we you and I
that's watching this year we have to be
very very careful for our own side to
not use that against us and for the
oppos position to not use it against us
because what happens when emotion goes
super super high then all of a sudden we
make emotional decisions and we look
back a month 3 months 6 months 12 months
later 10 years later and we say damn we
were like we were part of the problem
that was a major major problem that led
to a catastrophic event worldwide
tension is so high right now that it's
making me want to question everything
for example on the last podcast when we
had Charlie Kirk on what was one of the
questions I asked Charlie was how did
Israel not know Hamas was going to
attack okay great question and then
Forbes comes out and says this you know
conspiracy to go viral with claims about
Israel Hamas conflict go a little lower
you know and and uh he's calling a he's
calling Charlie Kirk and standoff down
keep going all the way down keep going
all the way down keep going all the way
down about the whole story on the pbd
podcast this this that and then while
they're writing this then they have
another story that comes out from Forbes
this video with Charlie this clip got
tens of millions of views on Twitter on
Tik Tok it fully went viral this clip
when the question was asked but you know
what else it's a good question to ask
here's the other
question the question is Egypt can save
gaza's civilians this is from Wall
Street Journal Egypt can save gaza's
civilians Israel's taken measures to Pro
protect civilians and gaza's operation
warning 1.1 million civilians to vacue
by the way 50% of people that live in
Palestine are kids wow and uh the
northern Gaza Strip while the Hamas
intentionally uses civilians as a human
Shields as noted by German foreign
minister analena barbach Hamas brings
nothing but suffering and death it is
hamas's perfidious perfidious strategy
to use a civilian population as a human
shield Egypt the only Escape rod for
Gaza civilians maintain strict entry
quotas as a Rafa Crossing fearing the
infiltration of Hamas terrorists this
hampers the evacuations of civilians
with 800 allowed to leave on Monday 800
they're asking 1.1 to leave Egypt is
saying only 800 are allowed as of Monday
and the crossing reply Clos recently
International pressure uh especially
from the United States should encourage
Egypt to open the Rafa Crossing to
prevent a humanitarian crisis and help
break hamas's control over Gaza
civilians here's the question who knows
Palestine and Gaza better us or Egypt EG
why isn't Egypt allowing them to cross
the border why are we so liberal in
America with allowing people to come
across the border how many terrorists
were found four Iranian people Rob if
you want to pull up that story yeah pull
this one up uh uh you just had it up a
couple minutes ago when you find it I'll
show it daily mail Pig and this is just
recently the four this is just recently
Rob just had it up four Iranians
considered a terrorist threat caught at
the US Mexico border as crossers from
countries with links to Israel were War
spikes right so I wish us treated the
border of people coming up from Mexico
the same way Egypt Protected Their order
of people coming down to their country
because you know what's Egypt's
responsibility who's their number one
priority their countries their people of
who else's responsibility is that so to
me the same question I have of how does
Israel the number one secret
intelligence organization in the world
Massad you didn't know Hamas was going
to do this and then to the people like
that's right Israel knew this was going
to happen they wanted you guys to fall
forward and mainstream media has been
behind it to all the people that are
liking that story my question back to
you is if the people of Gaza
Palestine Hamas are so friendly and
gentle and kind that you say they are no
one knows them better than their
nextdoor neighbor who knows your
neighbor better than you on what they do
on the weekends if you've lived next to
them for hundreds of years you're going
to know when they barbecue you're going
to know when they talk you're going
to know when they do parties you're
going to know how drunk that you're
gonna know that Auntie that comes out a
fights breakout you're gonna know which
kid is a trouble You're Gonna Know Who
sneaks and girls in the back you're
going to know all of that stuff and if
you do why do you say nope you guys
can't come here why would you say that
both are V very valid question you asked
this question last week you got me
thinking about about the whole thing
where hey Egypt if you want to do
something about it let him in why don't
you it's a valid question so to both
sides if you can't entertain two ideas
at the same time and be willing to be
wrong you're just as much as part of the
problem as the people are no I'm only
going to believe this side you're the
problem you have to entertain both ideas
to see what's really taking place here
or else you're causing the emotions to
go high for us to make some dumb
decisions that could cost millions of
people's lives this is not one of those
stories that could end up being only
5,000 people 5,800 people this could go
like this ready you ever seen these
fires in California boom one little
match boom and
then wind winds it Hawaii the win Boom
game over it could go that quickly so
make sure
you and I if you watch this some of you
watch us cuz you love what we have to
say but many of you also watch us cuz
you hate what we have to say but the few
of you that watch it because we do our
best to be fair to entertain both ideas
that group we have to be louder we have
to be louder to get people to entertain
both ideas that's my biggest concern
with this thing here my concern is that
people going to jump to conclusion
without weighing both options and then
all of a sudden boom we have World War
III and I we're sitting there saying how
did 82 people in our community in
Florida die how did 17 innocent kids in
school in Kansas City die how did 29
people like that kid that got who's the
kid did you see the the two uh uh young
kids in Chicago what was the one that
just happened and there was one in Texas
I think yeah these stories dude what did
these kids do yeah these kids didn't do
anything this is the Muslim boy killed
and women wounded in Illinois hate crime
motivated by isra homas War you can go
to The Other Side Stories on both sides
taking place everywhere this the
beginning by this is just the beginning
trust me America especially those that
live in America trust me America you
don't want this okay you do not want
this there's a reason why fire is so
ight now and people are worried because
they're worried that this could come to
their backyard and FYI if you're
listening to this you could be a part of
that problem because you and I are just
seeing one side of the story that's all
I have to say go ahead yeah let me put
on my pretend I'm a diplomat hat so Pat
when you left Iran in 1990 what year did
you leave Iran November 28th no no when
I left Iran was July 15th 89 okay July
89 you didn't go just go straight to
America you didn't go straight to
Germany you lived in a what ref Refuge
camp in Germany so if I'm going to be a
diplomat and try to provide a solution
you know Israel Gaza where they where
they what separates them from Egypt
which I totally agree that there should
be a border crossing safe haven for
refugees is something called the Sinai
Peninsula a refugee camp should be set
up established and vet everyone that
comes into these camps how was your
family vetted like crazy like did they
that they want to understand who your
father was who you were you were
probably 10 years old at the time but
I'm assuming all the young men women
included as well but specifically the
military age men were completely vetted
before you were let into the country or
certainly until you were let in America
similar yeah if you if you just kind of
punch in on the Sinai Peninsula right
there
so that's that's a solution that could
be done here because you can't just
basically here's what's happening Israel
is basically saying get the hell out of
Gaza we are coming full force for Hamas
we do not want to kill civilians please
leave now what is Hamas saying saying
stay we need you we need you to stay
here why because Hamas uses its citizens
to protect Hamas whereas Israel uses the
IDF to protect its citizens let me say
that again Hamas uses its citizens to
protect Hamas as human Shields whereas
the IDF will use uh will protect its
citizens so if you if if um if Israel if
Hamas put down all their guns all their
weapons there would be peace if Israel
put down all their guns and all their
weapons they would all be dead the moral
equivalency is not even close so what
what by the way if you've seen the
speaking of Egypt let me just highlight
some of the countries that have come out
pro-israel anti-israel or Pro Hamas here
are the countries that have basically
come out pro-israel so you just figure
out what side you stand on for the
countries that I'm about to name
countries that are pro-israel USA the UK
Germany France Italy India Canada
Australia New Zealand and 70 other
Democratic free countries countries that
are anti-israel pramas Iran Lebanon
Syria turkey Iraq Saudi Arabia turkey
China Venezuela I mentioned turkey twice
um and all the Communist authoritarian
regimes again the Horseshoe notice a
country that wasn't mentioned they're
just sort of Monolithic and they're not
saying anything right now Egypt they're
like dude we can't come out and promote
peace with Israel even though they have
peace with Israel but in no way shape or
form using the neighbor analogy are we
coming out condoning what's going on
here being and no one knows them better
than their neighbor of course so if if
um yeah the the thing to me that it in
it you know civilians um the objective
of Hamas is to kill civilians the
objective of the US Army the IDF whether
it's the UK actually Democratic normal
modern world countries is the intention
to not kill civilians and at the end of
the day I was actually watching an
interview uh on the BBC it was uh the
former prime minister navali Bennett he
said this he goes let me ask you
something he askes to the reporter let
me ask you let me ask you something if
someone was shooting at you and your
family and they were hi fting behind
civilians what would you do would you
shoot back answer that if so everyone
should answer that if someone was
shooting at
you shooting at your family and they
were standing behind civilians okay what
would you do what would you do Vin I'm
shooting you're shooting back kill
obious it's kill or be killed 100% so if
if someone's trying to kill you you have
two choices try to kill them or be
killed and that's essentially the
situation that's going on in is Israel
right now is that they're literally
trying to kill them Y and they're like
dude I don't want to have to kill
innocent civilians but you leave me no
choice Y and that's essentially the
problem P you you mentioned this uh
Forbes wrote the article about
conspiracy theorists like they're saying
uh Charlie Kirk uh that uh Israel knew
uh Hamas would attack right then they
contradict themselves they write an
article the next day that says us
intelligent reports included warnings
from September and October that the CIA
and other uh Middle Eastern allies knew
and so they could have prevented it so
and follow me Pat like and they're
acting like it doesn't matter but we
they should have been on high alert they
were warned September 28th they were
warned October 5th it's it's just crazy
like when are we going to stop
pretending that nobody knew and when are
we going to hold people accountable for
instance they asked John Kirby at the
white house uh uh reporter for the
massive security failure you know what
his answer was now's not the time time
like everybody no no no I think it's of
course now is the time we're moving
forward they're about to attack I mean
dude this is like a godsend I guess so
some more children could leave you know
why they haven't invaded in Gaza Pat the
weather there's weather so everybody's
slowing down thank God so hopefully more
kids get out of there but like like
decisions are being made just like in um
with when we invaded Iraq we went in all
weapons of mass destruction war war war
then we bomb the out of everybody
and then they're like oh by the way no
weapons of mass destruction like it's
too late answers need to be answered
right the questions need to be answered
and here's my question Charlie brought
this up at is it so farfetched is it I'm
I'm being genuine that a leader that's
kind of you know controversial is not
going that good for him there's bring of
Civil War in your in your country is is
it crazy to let an event like what just
happened happen to unify everybody so
nobody looks at you and they all look at
the issue and if it is true I'm going to
ask you out if it is true that this
genuinely happened they had intelligence
because the proof is in the pudding it
looks like they did and they kind of
went like this and let their people die
okay same type of with 911 what
what what then what do Adam real
question what do the people do what do
you do I'll answer that I mean and
Charlie Kirk brought up the question was
a stand out order uh order yeah um I
think it's two things I think it's
number one fair to ask that question %
but I also think it is unfair to draw a
conclusion we don't know do you know
with 100% certainty I don't know correct
so but my question is fair right now ask
the question okay ask the question to
draw the conclusion that BB Netanyahu
gave a standown order I think is very
unfair and very uninformed by anyone
who's asking but but no but but here's
my question the fact that there's proof
that the CIA knew intelligence knew
Egyptians warned them days before and
this still happened in a place that is
the most secure place besides us I mean
I I would say that Loosely like right
now is the time to answer like everybody
I know you guys you're going to war but
time out for one second how the hell did
you not ra like raise the flag put
security beef up security and and I get
what you're saying it's the question
needs to be answered now not in two
years where we go backwards and all
these people are dead and we go oh
you know what we kind of knew and you
know this guy over here messed up with
the intelligence and didn't run it up
the flag pole that's I think
Adam has a point there you can go back
and you can look at World War II and pro
Harbor and there's books that were
written that FDR and the American
intelligence knew the Japanese would try
to bomb Pearl Harbor and that's why the
aircraft carriers weren't there they
were all out on patrols they were all
out on there well what genius figured
out that if the Japanese were going to
attack something they were coming by
boat go take a look at the map yeah I
what other way they would have arrived
and so there's a lot of people that say
that and now you have to say the
conclusion so I'm with Adam on this one
the conclusion would be FDR sacrificed
2,000 men at Pearl Harbor so we could
get into into the Pacific War with Japan
no it was good strategy to keep the
aircraft carriers out was there bad
intelligence or incomplete intelligence
yeah but books have been written over
the course of history of could have
Shoulda did you know when you know but
but I have a hard time believing that BB
netu wanted to sacrifice Israeli
citizens to get into the war and to
permanently remove Gaza as his excuse to
get in just as I don't believe that FDR
left us vulnerable in Pol
harb what year was Pearl Harbor 1941
1941 this is 2023 our technology bro we
have satellites that could look through
people's houses and my cousin Mike told
me that Pat one of his guys that's in
talk talking about I agree talk about
intelligence Israel intelligence and our
intelligence I agree on the how do you
not know how do you not know I agree on
the technology but we're talking about
the same human decision whether you're
dealing with boats in World War II or
you're dealing with Gaza and paragliders
is would that leader trigger be to get
his country triggered into the war
sacrifice people it's the same moral and
my and my question was I just posed the
question I said is it so far-fetched
that a human being or Netanyahu Bush Jr
all these to me I'm not calling
nah I'm talking about Bush Jr you mean
to tell me like it's so far-fetched that
weapons of mass destruction because of
bush Jr's decision of they have these
weapons he's not stupid Tom they got us
into that war and then change the name
of the war after it was set by the way
by the way here's here's what I think
for the non emotionally involved party
we should entertain all those ideas okay
for the non- emotionally involved party
we should all entertain all of those
ideas if I'm in a military guess what
I'm writing down I'm writing down all
possibilities I'm if I'm if I'm working
with the president right now I'm one of
the advisers President Biden says hey
pbd what do you think happening it's
okay let's look at this is how we look
at the decision all right let's look at
five things Hamas in the last 10 years
have advanced their military so much
that they're apparently better than
mosad better than CIA better than Navy
Seals better than special ops better
than IDF better than everybody maybe
that is a possibility what's the
percentage behind that put a possibility
1% 2% 5% okay fine they're underground
you know whatever tunnels they built
it's so Advanced and that's what they're
doing cool let's put that as a
possibility two you know nety who needed
confirmation from the world to be able
to attack that because he saw the case
study of how Russia went against Ukraine
and in this situation where things he
thinks would be different in this
situation he is Russia but in this
situation
the world and NATO would defend Russia
meaning where NATO defended Ukraine in
this situation Ukraine is Hamas let's
just say I'm saying like not Hamas but
Palestine and Russia is Israel but
imagine if Russia attacks Ukraine and
NATO defends Russia what would happen to
Ukraine oh my God within a week they're
what they're done imagine if we gave
Russia $100 billion there is no Ukraine
Ukraine is not part of Russia right Russ
in this case Israel is the superpower
the Middle East let's just say from the
military side Okay so maybe Israel did
this to get the world permission of you
know the 6-h hour standown all that
stuff okay that is a possibility Mr
President what percentage you think
that's there let's put a number there
whatever that percentage is number three
maybe what's going I would go through
all of these scenarios and collectively
ask for Intel get the smartest guys
there and ask the question why isn't
Egypt letting people in if Egypt if if
they're so great why aren't they let him
in what is the chance of Iran getting
involved here who's Russia going to
defend is if if you know Israel does
attack Gaza and wipes out 20,000 people
Iran's going to call Hezbollah and
Hezbollah attacks is do we should we
believe the threat that the Hamas makes
that if you attack us we're going to
kill these hostages that we have one by
one by one and we're going to air it so
you can see how humiliating this is and
you're going to feel the pain you're
killing those people so the blood's
going to be on Whose hands netanyahu's
hands for killing the I'm going to put
all that stuff up then you have to take
a risk nobody knows 100% what's going on
every one of those things should be
weighed however
Ben Shapiro and Tucker Carlson okay I
want to read this and Rob if you can get
this clip prepared Ben Shapiro contemns
Tucker for downplaying Attack on Israel
its idiocy is just moral stupidity Ben
Shapiro strongly condemns Saker Carlson
accusing them moral stupidity and
criticized them for downplaying the
recent attack shapir K Tucker Carlson
comparing between the Israel tragedy and
drug abuse deaths in United States
declaring he attempting he's attempting
to minimize as though America can't walk
and Shu come morally speaking at the
same time which is absurd I'll just let
you watch this clip uh uh to judge it
for yourself go ahead rob th000 a year
now you could call it genocide you can
call it whatever you want but it's the
death of over a 100,000 Americans a year
and the living death of millions well
you can't call it genocide it's not
genocide so I don't understand people
who are addicted to drugs and living
outside Israel and again I I want to add
my voice to that cuz I'm a human being
but oh sure the the outrage among
Republican presidential candidates was
so much more intense one of them took to
a bullhorn and start yelling about it I
get it but no one would think to do that
about the 100,000 American young people
murdered every year and they because who
are you yelling at who are you yelling
at first of all people are on bullhorns
yelling about drug overdoses and the
open border all the time all the time
what is he even talking about what he's
attempting to is minimize what happened
in Israel he's not attempting to
maximize what happened in the United
States he's attempting to minimize as
though America can't walk and Che G
morally speaking at the same time which
is absurd and those two things are
nothing alike I'm sorry that is not
alikee it is not alike for drug
smugglers to smuggle drugs over the
board which someone then takes and
shoves into their arm and then they dive
in overdose that is not the same thing I
promise you it is not the same thing as
a terrorist breaking into your home and
murdering your children in their beds in
front of you and dragging your wife off
to be raped in Gaza that is not the same
thing pretending that it is is IM moral
it's a moral blight it's idiocy it's
just moral stupidity at the highest
level of course we should care about
what happens with fentanyl of course we
should care about all we should close
our border have I been unclear about
this of course America should have
closed borders when it comes to this
sort of stuff I'm on the same side as
Tucker on that I just don't understand
why he's not on my side when it comes to
Hamas has to be wiped off the face of
the Earth pause it right there what
exactly is the counter aru Tom Adam go
ahead yeah well uh it's it's interesting
to see how this is playing out because
this is sort of a fissure of what's
going on in the in the Republican right
um in my opinion Ben chapiro just
completely owned Tucker Carlson uh let
me unpack that a little bit so the the
trying to draw equivalency between what
Hamas is doing or what Isis did it
whether it becomes rapes mass murder
intentional genocide versus the active
decision to consume drugs over long
periods of time in some cases and then
dive in overdose is
completely absolutely absurd the moral
equivalence knowing the risk of partying
when you did it correct so it and and
just like Ben said do we want to fix our
borders yes do we want to stop fentol
from pouring into our country yes but at
the end of the day people who are using
drugs very few people take it one time
and die very few it's over it's a it's a
long slow process so to decision to
actively take drugs heroin pills cocaine
whatever the drug is and use it and use
it and use it and use it and eventually
die okay you're making this active
decision nobody made an active decision
in Israel to be sitting in your homes at
at 6:00 in the morning Hamas bust in
your door and shoots you and your babies
in the head that is a totally different
situation so in my opinion Ben Shiro is
spot on on this one and Tucker is just
blatantly wrong Tom uh I have my
thoughts I want to hear your thoughts
well I I agree you know Tucker did not
sound outraged and it sounded like he
was balancing the argument um and then
Ben gets pretty revved up uh Ben's a
and he gets pretty revved up and I think
he is correct that you can't draw moral
equivalency with a decisionist thing
because you happen to be Jewish and
you're attacked and a decision to be on
college campus aren't you worried about
fenel yeah I'm worried about fentanyl
just get one of those fentanyl test kits
you can get those test kits and you can
rub the rub the pill on it see if
there's any fentel in there but yeah
there's a big difference between the two
of those and I think Tucker was was
you know could have done a better job
and left the door open to kind of be
owned by Shapiro here's what I would say
number one um I think I totally
understand Tucker and I totally
understand Ben okay number one Tucker
what's Tucker's number one loyalty and
Affinity America First what are we
talking about America First he's going
to sit there and say yeah to that's your
problem first of all this Sunday we with
the family and for whatever reason Tik
and Dylan wanted to watch Zohan okay I
don't know if you guys know Zohan with
Adam Sandler whatever the movie what's
the movie called The Legend Of
Z by the way you know the whole story is
about how he's a IDF killer Soldier
comes to us wants to work for Paul
Mitchell cutting here and he goes and
finally becomes this hair stylist at
this salon and the owner of the salon is
gorgeous girl who's a Palestinian and
they fall in love and they're trying to
bring peace between Palestine and Israel
what a weird movie to watch at a time
like this Jen and I are looking at each
other laughing but at the same time
saying everything he's talking about
they're talking about right now PES to
current times okay Ben Tucker's priority
is America First of course he's going to
be about America he's sitting there
saying dude these guys have been
fighting for 2,000 years you think I can
stop it yeah you guys been fighting for
thousands of years one day America's
going to wake up and stop you guys from
fighting it's a joke if we think this
fight's going to end up anytime soon
that's how I think that Tucker sees it
but I also see Ben guess where Ben is
from there that's his family that's
where he's from of course he's going to
be protective
of his homeland his pride you know he
you know the voice he has for the Jewish
Community 100% he's going to see that
from an emotional connection to it one
has to sit there and entertain both
ideas is all I'm saying both could be
right and both could be emotionally
leaning towards whatever is protective
of theirs yeah Tucker is going to
protect America and Ben is going to
protect Israel in a way that hey we got
to make sure this is number one priority
to Tucker no one in the world has been
able to prevent this fight from
happening for 2,000 years including God
you think you can do it y Let Them Fight
they're going to keep fighting okay let
them fight they're going to go back and
forth but do we want to involve our
soldiers now America's talking about the
fact that report came out we're
preparing 2,000 soldiers to be sent out
about 2,000 US troops told to prepare
for deployment and response to Israel
Hamas War Hamas War this is an NBC story
a couple days ago okay I'll read the
story for you
for you to think about so here you go so
around 2,000 soldiers 24-hour
preparation to deploy orders ready to
provide support to Israel in response to
the Hamas Israel war the troops include
the diverse capabilities such as medical
support and explosive handling and were
previously on 96-hour standby the US has
already deployed the USS Dwight
Eisenhower carrier strike group to
Eastern Mediterranean Sea shown
solidarity with Israel Israel Defense
Forces are amassing forces at the Gaza
border a preparing for coordinated
attack involving the airca on the land
the conflict began a significant
terrorist attack by Hamas and Israel
resulting in over 2800 casualties in
Gaza and, 1400 casualties in Israel
guess what those are 2,000 US soldiers
those are somebody's kids what do you
call that and what do you call that Pat
we're sending the aircraft carriers and
then Pat ready for this you were in the
military 2,000 people ready to go
they're already declared war if we go
there and we put troops on the ground
what does that mean we're at War of
course we're at War and P here's my
thing with the Ben Shapiro thing Tom
like Ben Shapiro and I get it bro this
is a horrible thing it's it's discussing
what happened all the people lives that
were lost but you can't expect other
people to match your emotion in a
situation and they're not invested as
much as you are I Ben is furious I get
it I understand it but he's expecting
Tucker to have the same outrage as him
and I'm sorry it's not you can't expect
that let me tell you Vinnie you you and
I are in America because of Jimmy Carter
okay at least I'm in America because of
Jimmy Carter okay Jimmy Carter goes to
you Iran and all he's talking about is
human rights human rights human rights
3,000 political prisoners that RZ palvi
had let him loose he lets him loose
those 3,000 political prisoners into uh
led to you know Osama Bin Laden led to
all the other things that happen around
the world led to all these Isis all
these different things at one point Brea
pal had him so on the outside we're like
yeah Jimmy Carter human rights as if you
know who the 3,000 political prisoners
are was there some situations that maybe
Sak and others were extreme of course
yeah just like there's stories of mad
just like there's stories of CI just
like there's of course yes us is also
not free from that situation of what CI
and mad and others have done but what
ended up happening is they ended up here
so what's my bigger concern here's my
bigger
concern we live in America okay so it's
like oh here's the pr here's the problem
here's a problem yeah but the PR's
coming through here through the border
and here's the problem here's a dude no
no no listen while you're looking there
there coming through the border and
they're coming to your home to your
country to your state to your city yeah
but watch what's going on in Ukraine and
Russia watch what's going on in Israel
and Iran bro for the freaking third time
they're coming through your border how
are you protecting it is Egypt more
concerned about their border than us is
concerned about our border can we not
take a page out of their playbook to sit
there and say this is why we need a
border this is this shouldn't a
Democratic or republican thing this
should be an American thing to say this
is a problem so watch this how long does
it take until they do their attack for
the people that are coming here is it a
month no here yeah is it three months no
is it 6 months no it's when everything
is good no one's paying attention eight
years from now we forgot about this
entir Miss and then boom 6,800 people
die and you say how did this do the
president's SP no no no no no it's going
to come back to 2021 2022 2023 2020 when
we let the Border open all of these
people came in and during this time half
the half the American people didn't
about it and then all of a sudden
you're suffering the consequences
because you said it's not a big deal we
should let the people in we should get
the Democratic party to get more
stronger because it's a lot of Latino
voters and we know Latino voters are
going to vote for the left if we bring
them in here and then you're going to
pay the price my
concern of America First is if there's
ever been a time to just say shut the
border up for one year made a video the
other day talking about policies I would
do if I was a president obviously I'm
not running for president the laws are
not favored in that I'm I'm a capitalist
you know what one of the first things I
would do today I would close the border
for one year we're not taking anybody
for a year it's a waiting list remember
when I got out of the Army in 99 I
wanted to be a firefighter and I went to
the fire department in Granada Hills off
of uh Devonshire and Balo right across
the street from Ralph's off the 101 uh
no no in uh Granada Hill so I go to this
recruiting station I say hey I just got
out the Army hunter for Airborne
Division I'm in shape I'm this I'm that
I love America I want to be a
firefighter we got a five-year freeze
what do you mean 2003 it opens up it's
99 I said dude you guys got to hire me
I'm fully qualified he says no there's a
5year freeze 5 years later they open up
the freeze but it's too late at that
time I'm doing good for myself what's
the moral of the story if the fire
department can have a freeze if the LA
Department LAPD can have a freeze if
companies can have a freeze in their
hiring so can we have a freeze in our
border for one year shut the southern
border down shut it down close it up
immediately build the wall fill it up
with additional security you want to
hire 87,000 new IRS agent why don't you
hire 30,000 new border agents put them
there protect the freaking place for one
year this is no longer a joke this is
serious you're seeing what's going on
there all the people that are fighting
you're seeing examples of the way
they're doing it protect the southern
border because that's where they're
coming through and then all of a sudden
people will say well yeah that's a
little extreme why would we do something
like that because that's how you live
you have doors you have walls you live
in a community where people have to ring
the
doorbell 82 yes yes we're here Uber Eats
I didn't order no Uber Eats oh I'm sorry
don't let them in why don't you let them
in because it's your border it's called
your apartment it's called your house
it's called your community if you want a
border in your apartment in your house
in your community why don't you want a
border in the southern border of America
again I'm not telling the people that
are already with this I'm telling the
people that are saying what's the big
deal that's what I'm talking to and and
great point and Adam I I'll I'll give it
to you here's the the eff up thing Pat
the Border after all this right now
still wide open nothing has changed my
orcus hasn't done anything if you still
have the attitude of what Pat just said
you know what they're going to say Pat
you're uncaring you're racist you don't
care this is what a America's force is
Open Arms you understand what I'm saying
Adam it hasn't changed one iota it's
still the same that it was since all
this is happening and nothing is
stopping so here's my question to you
guys Pat what can we do us as a people
right now to try to get that message
where it's like yo like shut it down is
there anything that there's nothing we
could do right Tom nothing you got to
vote you got to talk no it's right now
right now what's like the border is wi
you and I are not going to under the
Second Amendment pick up arms and go
pick some part of the border that we're
going to defend that's not the way it
works you know we we need the leadership
of this country and the governors of
Texas the governor of Arizona the
governor now you know of um oh by the
way governors of Illinois and New York
because all of those people coming
across were supposed to stay in those
red states make life miserable for the
red States and be the replacement vote
later look up replacement vote people
Google that yeah instead they are now
being shipped to not by DeSantis sending
a couple buses to New York the federal
freaking government sending a dozen
buses of them dropping them in Chicago
dropping them in New York until you have
the governor in New York governor in
Illinois saying oh you know we don't
need the people here well look look
Upstream where is it so we need the
governors we need all of them to get
together to say we need sensible border
policy because close the border
everybody's going to say racist sensible
immigration policy is the way that this
needs to be
adopted on The Wider basis yeah and but
Tom you said it's you know we can't the
Second Amendment we can't just take arms
and go but in the Constitution it's for
enemies foreign and domestic at one
point we're going to have to be like yo
listen if you guys aren't doing it we'll
do it there's enough Americans out there
bro that'll go up there and post the
hell up and like yo it's enough because
he nailed it Tom this might ranchers
hang on I I'm not I think you just I
appreciate your passion but what about
all those ranchers that were in Arizona
that got arrested but but Tom I
understand being arrested but he made a
great point the government did not let
the citizens protect the Border I think
it's Tom because you know what
he he nailed it this might not happen
this week that Hamas loser tried to be
like a day of terrorism it didn't happen
it's eventually going to happen because
we have no idea who the hell we let in
like enough is enough when are we going
to stop yapping and do I'm not
saying go there with a gun and be at the
border but like come on man enough is
enough and then we keep bringing my
orcus in Congress and he just sits there
with a smirk and smiles and laughs in
our faces because they already know the
damage has been done Tom the damage is
done the people are here now it's a
waiting game it's a waiting game for
when they get the call to to make
happen and it's going to happen sleep
let me kind of try to put a ribbon on
this entire argument because it started
off the conversation with Ben Shapiro
Tucker Carlson uh comparing the analogy
of uh murder and execution and rape and
beheadings to fentanyl crisis I I hear
what Pat is saying and it's reminiscent
of what Trump said is build the wall
we'll have a big beautiful door and
we'll vet the hell out of people because
we don't want this basically migrant
crisis pouring through our country
totally understand totally understand
the America First agenda totally get it
totally get it what Ben Shapiro said was
you know America should have the ability
to walk and chew gum at the same time
morally speaking America whether you
agree with this or not we have a
domestic policy and a foreign policy
uh and it's always been that case are we
going to be isolationists and only
pretend that we exist in America in a
bubble and the rest of the world doesn't
exist I think that is a nonsensical
solution it's never been that way never
been that way are we going to be
absolute interventionalists and get and
dip our toes into every single conflict
that exists around the world we'll drive
ourselves crazy doing that so the point
is we kind of done that exactly so the
point is there needs to be a balance and
there be new um a Nuance perspective to
how this works so the reason that we're
uh going to bat for Israel at this point
is because they're our Ally in the
Middle East it's a fair exchange of
value a lot of it has to do with
military intelligence and basically
information that go that occurs in the
Middle East who else are we going to
come to their defense are we coming to
Iran's defense Saudi Arabia are we
helping Lebanon who do we trust there we
trust Syria Bashar al- Assad there are
one Ally that we know we can 100% depend
on in the Middle East and ultimately
here's the point so America is a land of
immigrants we all come from some place
so if you don't speak up when something
is completely morally and historically
wrong like the murder of people
intentionally how do you let this happen
who do you what do you stand for America
who do you believe in when do you speak
out so when this happens in Armenia and
there's Armenian Genocide do we say hey
that's none of our business when it
happens in Mexico hey Mexicans hey it's
none of our business when this happens
in Ireland it's none of our business
at some point we have to say we're
freaking America we stand for something
and we're not just going to let innocent
people be murdered but by the way
absolutely valid argument valid point as
a person who's Armenian and and seeing
what's going on with nagoro kabak and
aeran and all that stuff I fully
understand being emotionally there okay
I fully understand but he wasn't there
when it was Armenia this was happening
he wasn't fully there with all of it
right why because it should matter to
you the most because it's personal it
this issue should be the most important
thing for you because it's your Homeland
right it should be personal to me as a
person who lived in Iran and when the
the Sha was there and Israel was there
there was peace in the Middle East and
people could go for vacation in the
Middle East and go to Iran we can't do
that today uh Armenian Genocide should
be emotional personal to me because I
half Armenian and ass Syrian and what
the genocide did to Assyrians and
Armenians 100% should be personal to me
but the the other person that's sitting
there saying dude should everyone's
problems be mine that person also has a
very good argument to make look at this
Wall Street Journal article that came
out a couple days ago Mexican senol
cartel's message to members stop making
fentol or die this analog cartel known
for exporting fentol to the US has
ordered a halt to product fentol
production and and trafficking within
his territory driven by pressure by from
US law enforcement the directive is
attributed to
uh uh chapitos led by wakin El Chapo
Guzman's Sons uh the Biden
Administration Administration has been
urging Mexico to take aggressive step to
dismantle the Seno cartel which is a
major fentol trafficking group us deaths
from fentol have become a political
issue with calls from some Republicans
to send US military to Mexico to battle
to combat fental trafficking some
individuals in Seno have faced violence
and death for defying the ban While
others are reluctant to shut down their
operations due to strong demand man for
fentol in the US so can you imagine the
Mexican Calo cartel a saint stop making
it that's a Feelgood story that's
murderers with moral morals that's a
murderers with morals even that's the
Italian mop story right hey we don't do
drugs we don't do this we don't do that
if you do it we're going to take you out
and if you did do it you got in trouble
although a lot of people ended up doing
it yeah so when it's that profitable
you're going to do it go ahead Tom
there's a great scene in The Godfather
where where movies sort of give us a
window into reality and it's when Marlon
Brando says
he did not want the drugs and he called
gambling prostitution harmless vices
remember the speech he gives and he says
I'm not in favor of the drugs he's
talking Salo Sal that's right I'm not in
favor of the drug thing he says but
harmless vies I me you know you don't
know whether this is window dressing or
whether these guys are looking saying
listen you know next year there's a an
election and a feel-good story for the
Americans in the election is they send a
couple Apache helicopters over here and
they take out my house yeah so so you
guys better knock it off and as a matter
of fact maybe I need to knock off a few
low-level guys to make this look good is
it that way that they're really they're
they're doing it and they're supported
by China and they're doing it anyway but
they're running a PR campaign where a
couple low-level drug dealers get
knocked you know get hit and they make
it look like they're trying to tow the
line because they do not want the US
military to come in there we did a very
good job did you hear what you just said
go back and repeat what you just said
they don't want the US milit go back a
story prior to that do they did they
knock off a couple of them to make it
look good as a PR campaign
exactly ex do you understand understand
was saying ago what you just said so
that's the part to give permission to be
like so that's the part why you ought to
consider that as a possibility even
though if it's a one or two% so there's
a part of me that reads this story and
thinks it's the the cartel's a public PR
is a strong fpr from can you imagine
yeah we represent the cartels the
Mexican Calo cartel in New York could
say
one of the biggest PR firms Bon Marell
here the largest PR firm in the United
States and we now our portfolio includes
by way there's this is not a time for
jokes but I remember there was a long
ago there was a a mockery that was done
because they invaded this this Major
Distribution place that was in um
Colombia that was wrapping it all up and
there was this room where you saw these
pictures
and the boxes of these Ziploc freezer
bags there was like 50,000 boxes of
these Ziploc freezer bags in there and
so it says some salesman at the Glad
ziplock it says really made quota on
these guys who's one of your bigger
customers well you know the cartels on
there they need the one PB freezer bags
for the cocaine and boy I got that pool
in my backyard because I cut the deal so
ziplock could have given them some Intel
of where they're buying where they're
shipping these bags
to get more information out
Adam talking about a PR campaign it's
essentially a PR campaign or even
propaganda is to give the illusion or
the facade that you're doing one thing
when you're actually kind of doing
another or to sort of um expound upon
what the greatness is but you may sort
of mitigate with the thing is don't
don't look now but what is Joe Biden
doing because this article right here
basically says the Biden Administration
has been urging Mexico to take
aggressive steps to dismantle the caloa
cartel the major fentol trafficking
group okay boom what are we seeing
lowkey from Joe Biden these days well
he's kind of building a little bit of a
wall yeah not sure if you Noti kind of
talking about that he's clearly taking a
hard line with Mexico lowkey so what's
the pr what's the facade listen we love
immigrants we love all that but lowkey
he's trying to play tough with Mexico
you know what he's doing he's realizing
everything all the policies Trump had
were successful so let me replicate
those policies without being too loud
about it because if God forbid people
find that it's their policies I'm going
to be in trouble cuz they're duplicating
what he's doing anyways let me go to the
next story here Tom and I want to get
your feedback on this with oil so one us
to ease sanctions on Venezuelan oil for
Freer presidential election interesting
these three stories I'll combine them
together and I'll give it to Tom very
interesting here the Biden
Administration in Venezuela this is from
wapo Washington Post the Biden
Administration and Venezuelan president
maduro's government have reached a
breakthrough deal in which the US will
ease sanctions on Medan oil industry in
exchange for commitment from the
authoritarian regime to hold a
competitive internationally monitored
presidential election in 20124 the
relief and sanctions will be announced
once an agreement is signed including
commitments by the Venezuelan government
to ensure a fair vote under the
agreement Maduro has agreed to process
for lifting bans on opposition
candidates running uh in its elections
it's also com uh includes commitments to
maduro's government to accept
International election electoral
observations and open media access for
elections actually very very interesting
let me continue with the other two
stories Exon Mobile buying Pioneer
Natural Resources for nearly $60 billion
in its biggest deal in decades this is a
forb story
okay this is a forb story in this story
you see uh uh Exon uh uh set to acquire
Pioneer Natural Resources a 60 billion
all stock they marking the largest deal
for Exon since it's merging with Mobile
in 19 late 1990s the acquisition will
acquire will value Pioneer at $253 a
share with Pioneer shareholders
receiving approximately 2.32 shares of
Exon Mobile for each share they own the
acquisition will give Exon Mobile uh
Pioneer share 850,000 net acres in the
perian peran basan in West Texas
effectively doubling its output in the
region which accounted for 18% of all
natural gas and last but not least
lithium Discovery in US volcano could be
the biggest deposit ever found uh uh a
significant lithium the deposit has been
identified in a volcanic crater along
the Nevada Oregon border potentially
containing between 20 to 40 million tons
of lithium metal which surpasses
previous deposits found in Bolivia the
discovery carries substantial Global
implications affecting lithium prices
supply chain security and geopolitical
Dynamics in the lithium Market mining
operations are projected to commence in
2026 aiming to extract lithium from the
claystone in an energy efficient and low
acid consumption matter Tom why do these
stories matter to the average American
we've been talking about the Middle East
and the Middle East is where there's a
lot of energy and the US has been a net
natural gas exporter this increases our
independence and increases our ability
to stand on the world stage and to
support Canada and other people with
energy needs so take a look Venezuela
Venezuela is right across the gulf
from galvaston and Houston Texas where
we have giant refineries down there and
by the way so Venezuela it's it's sort
of comical hey if you promise promise
promise to be good tonight I'll give you
ice cream okay if you promise to have
fair and open elections in Venezuela and
stop knocking off opposition candidates
tell you what I'll take off the
sanctions on men your Venezuelan oil M
Venezuela is a member of everyone
everyone OPC OPC yes they're the they're
the redheaded stepchild way across the
Atlantic Ocean and so that brings
Venezuelan oil here so that we can take
advantage of that Exxon buys up this so
that they could do and you've heard it
before you hear when the uh conservative
candidates say it what should our energy
policy be drill baby drill well guess
what Exon just found more places to
drill baby drill cuz West Texas WTI when
you see in the Wall Street Journal uh
the average price for you know light
sweet crude Saudi Arabia and for WTI
crude WTI is West Texas intermediate and
the peran Basin is this giant giant
Basin over there Midland Odessa Texas
where we have all this crude so this is
Exxon getting access to even more crude
why is this important well to get the
prices for gas artificially down about a
year ago Joe Biden drained What's called
the spr Strategic petroleum Reserve
that's where we keep oil that if there's
a major Calamity maybe it's weather
maybe it's hurricane that takes out
galvaston you don't know what it could
be but that was supposed to be the place
that we dip to it in a time of emergency
instead what he did he was trying to
drop the price of gas um artificially on
the short-term basis and people said you
know you shouldn't be doing this and now
you have to refill it so this is all
part of of further further American
Energy Independence and America as an
energy power the globalists don't want
us to be an energy power they want us to
be dependent that's why the greens line
up with the globalists to say oh don't
don't drill no pipelines and don't go
into anoir anir basically is Drilling in
Alaska where there's a ton of oil ladies
and gentlemen so this is what this is
all about this is whose Victory is this
this is a victory for United States
energy Independence that's great and
finally and Biden is doing what Trump
was doing with Venezuela why shouldn't
they be allowed to take their oil over
to us why don't we buy it but I'm
trailing you all signs of every policy
that was working under Trump Biden has
finally realized that if you want to get
reelected you got to use those policies
cuz that's exactly what's important to
America wall oil Independence you're
seeing all these stories secure well
they're not doing the Border Side but by
the way by the way the lithium Discovery
is an unexpected good news for the
American that's fantastic news because
the how does musk feel about that how
does musk feel about that uh he's he's
been in he's taken exceptionally long
shower this is he launching a missile he
needed a big cold shower because he's
really happy about this cuz it means we
don't have to rely over time as this
becomes as this discovery becomes mined
and available for sale it means you
don't have to rely on on China Chile or
very expensive lithium extraction from
seawater to get this heavy mineral that
you need to make batteries for electric
vehicles and there's a lot more to it
those batteries that you see Tesla cells
that go on the wall of garages that
could basically power the house for a
day and a half those that's a big part
of it too all about less Reliance
globally and this is exactly the stuff
that Trump would have been on top of
quick antidote for you Tom because great
explanation I appreciate that you said
how does this affect America well I'll
tell you how this affects my life and
affects our lives here in South Florida
so uh you may be familiar that in the
1980s and even prior to that there was
uh the Cuban uh entrance into Miami
basically Cuban helped build Miami along
with a lot of um local Jewish community
and and you know there's something
called Little Havana and cocho and the
there's a major major Cuban presence in
Miami BB Roso there you go so uh slowly
but surely uh Little Havana and
everything that's going on has sort of
been uh shifting towards what I call
Little karakas because uh that's the
capital of Venezuela Venezuelans are
pouring into legally speaking pouring
into Miami and and basically setting up
shop in Miami and saying we ain't going
back to freaking Venezuela that's great
that there's diplomatic relations kind
of going on the oil the sanctions
everything going on right there but
here's the one thing they should know
when the Cubans first came here uh they
were anti-communist anti-socialist anti-
Fidel Castro and they voted with the
Republican party with Reagan and and
socially shed up that block what's
happening right now I know we talk about
the open borders and sort of the Latin
American countries in Mexico pouring in
and basically under the Democratic guide
of remember who let you in don't forget
these people who are basically leaving
the Maduro regime via um shavez regime
uh will definitely be remembering uh the
Socialist Communist lifestyle uh and
remember that when they vote for most
likely Republicans in the upcoming
election assuming they're allowed to
vote okay so that's that let's get to
the next story I think we got a couple
more stories here to go through before
we wrap up uh one of the stories uh
Vinnie I'm going to go to this year and
then I'm going to get into the Jada
pinket story
uh here's a story from military times
nearly 70% of active members are
overweight report fines
70% of active military duty is out uh is
overweight so a report of American
Security part reveals that two3 of
Americans uh of soldiers active duty
members fall within overweight or obese
category the body mass index BMI the
obesity rate within a military base on
BMI has more than doubled over the past
decade rising from are you kidding me
rising from 10 to 21% the report
emphasizes need for addressing this
issue particularly in the context of
military Recruitment and Readiness to
grow an obesity rate amongst service
members are seen as alarming effect in
the military's ability to recruit an
adequate labor force the report
recommends reviewing body composition
standards referring troops with high BMI
to specialized doctors for obesity
treatment with including BMI data and
Report provided to Congress what is the
recruiting and rtion what are we talking
about here what's your thoughts on this
story you well first of all Pat the
numbers for recruitment is at an like
it's Tom nobody's joining the military
I'm actually worried Pat cuz not only
70% out of shape is absolutely uh
ridiculous which has doubled in the past
10 years look at how what else has the
military been doing this year we lost
for a week uh F35 $85 million plane they
had no idea where the hell it was and
then they came out and asked the public
hey do you guys know where it is it's
like wait a minute you're the military
you know I mean how are you asking us
where a stealth fighter is I mean
apparently I think they found it they
crashed somewhere in the ocean but uh
Pat I'm genuinely worried cuz besides
the weight besides the losing technology
not not keeping up with what's happening
in the world with uh intelligence we're
paying the military pays for girls to
have boob jobs and if you want to
transition they'll they're paying for
people to have transition surgery your
tax dollar your tax dollar is going for
that it's the military is getting weak
and with all the stuff that's happening
in the world this is the worst time to
have overweight woke surgery having
people that are like when cuz Tom we're
we we've gotten LAX of days agal because
nothing has happened there's hasn't been
no Wars there hasn't been no deployments
it's it's it's a scary thing because I'm
not saying Pat we need practice but
something needs to happen with the
training and something needs to happen
Tom to keep them on their toes because
if 70% are overweight God forbid some
ground Invasion happens I think
we're in bad shape Tom I I I agreee I
think it's part of a a bigger and longer
five week podcast on America's health
and and and what's going on but I think
this is this is disgraceful and but I go
Upstream why can't we get young people
with a patriotic eye to serve their
country well we you look what happening
in the schools and stuff we're having
trouble recruiting them and the ones we
can recruit we're having what they're
saying is I can't get enough people that
are in shape that want to defend their
country so I'm having to the criteria to
people who are softer and bigger and I
think that's P go Pat do you like no
wonder why numbers are down if you wave
a flag people are like you're you're
you're racist patriotism is at an
all-time low you can't even say that you
love being American CU people think that
it's a shitty thing to say that doesn't
surprise me so so by the way just
beautifully put together number one love
of the country you have to have that you
got to have love and pride for the
country you represent others have it uh
uh our educational system is not
increasing love and pride in our country
that's number one number two it's a very
good point Tom number two our standards
have dropped okay we are trying to be
way too soft allowing trans allowing you
know it's okay to do lgbtq and to do
this and to do that we have to be more
such and such your enemy doesn't give a
if you're gay stray trans or black
or white or Hispanic they don't care
they want to kill you and the only thing
you can do to protect your country is to
be seen feared and respect it and the
enemy today doesn't fear us and they
don't respect us why would anybody
respect an enemy who's out of shape this
guy's going to run out of breath after
30 seconds
of I can't do this can you tell them to
stop let's take a break nobody takes a
break in Ward there are no timeouts in
war and G there may be timeout hey coach
I'm out of breath you can't go and say
hey Hamas can you let's take a quick 30
second time out in this war here let's
take a quick 30 seconds let's take a
full full time out full time out to get
a break that doesn't happen in war so
it's pretty embarrassing and pathetic to
say the least I'll add one thing is that
you know on my show in the sast we have
all these women on and we have these
conversations about what's going on with
modern day feminism and basically the
body positivity movement and I'm not
sure if you've seen the latest Victoria
Secret fashion show situation and just
all shapes and sizes and sort of
redefining what beautiful is and there's
zero uh fat shaming allowed there's zero
accountability hey you can as big as be
as big as you want to be and the problem
with that is that we didn't essentially
look on the other side of the equation
when it comes to men men have no problem
being like dude you're you're complete
slop you're completely out of shape get
it together but women will not do that
to each other they will not hold each
other accountable if someone's big
they'll like oh you're big you're a
queen or whatever but to see that
happening in the military to today is
just sort of uh indicative of where
we're at you know they said the
military's gone woke go woke go broke um
the exactly the new Victoria
um but it it's I don't know if this is a
food
thing are you saying bring back fat
shaming in the military is that kind of
what you're saying that's exactly what
I'm saying slight buling I mean at least
not being a little bullying and P it's
funny it's funny you brought up the gays
and the military by the way their their
numbers are so down it went from when we
were in to don't ask don't tell now it's
we don't give a we need we need you
and this is a fun this is random P but
this is a a fact did you know in
1994 Government tried to use gay as a
weapon did you know that they they were
proposed to bill the Department of
Defense $7.5 million to create a gay
bomb a bomb a chemical that when it when
it blew up Google if you think I'm lying
Rob look it up Pat this chemical would
hit the enemy Pat and make them
irresistible to each other something
tells me Vinnie that much like theb Le
that leaked somehow here in America
buddy go go okay there you go gay bomb
uh informly known as a non-lethal
psychemon concept that was speculated
upon a research laboratory within the
United States Air Force the
unconventional idea involved the the
dispersion of sex uh fur over enemy
forces with the intent of generating
Mutual sexual attracting among them
causing Mass
confusion and panic within their platoon
dating back to 94 the right laboratory
in Ohio a persecutor to the modern
United States Air Force research
laboratory drafted a three-page proposal
detailing several potential non chemical
weapons the document eventually acquired
by Sunshine project freedom of
informative act request explores a
notion of the gay bomb among other con
can you can you imagine this Adam we're
fighting in the Middle East and there's
two Middle Easterns like in a foxhole
and the gate bomb hits and he's like the
smoker is like Amir are you okay he's
like no he's like what can I do to help
he's like
well get back there and like dude could
you imagine using like that's that's
that's the type of money that they were
wanting to spend way too many good jokes
with this how funny is that but it's a
fact wow you told me to find gems that's
a gem maybe they dropped a lot of gay
bombs in a few different places in
America youever go down if you ever go
down the rabbit hole of CIA and
Department of Defense drug and other
testing you will find that they were
trying anything a lot of it didn't work
but they were trying anything and they
would experiment with it okay all right
let's go to the last
story The Last Story P have you seen J
Pink's recent book that have you read it
I have not read it got that for sure had
read it so Jada pink if you want to pull
up the story so I can read this she just
recently wrote a book pull up the New
York Post story uh Will Smith's Will
Smith heartbroken shocked over Jada
Pink's book worthy take a rest go a
little lower to read this year so uh
Will Smith speaks continuously about the
Bombshells of his AR strange wife J
Smith and her Numa more worthy the 55y
Oscar winner pinned a a um letter to
British podcast author and life Co J
shett who read the message to uh Jada
pinkin on a episode of her podcast I
just turned the final page of worthy
wrote Smith it is amazing to realize
that despite having lived most of my
Life by your side I still find myself
shocked and stunned caught off guard
laughing then inspired then heartbroken
I was all over the place he continued
it's one thing to hear anecdotes at a
family barbecue but it was truly
overwhelming to take your uh Tak in your
story and potential uh po potently
condensed in this way Smith seemed to
have a largely positive effect on pinket
Smith who married in 1997 and the
regards to their own actions I know it
wasn't easy to ex this way I applaud you
and honor you in the letter if I had
read this book 30 years ago I definitely
would have hugged you more I'll start
now welcome to author's Club I love you
endlessly now get home get Sumer low and
take a RK and he says you know I can't
drink Sumer low and and by the way
apparently in the the memo they have
been uh uh separated for seven years
2016 so they've been apparently
separated so Austin happened afterwards
so they've been separated for seven
years so when the Oscar thing happened
Pat you realize not Oscar Austin the
guy son AUST
friend best friend or whatever but go
ahead what are your thoughts on this I
have some thoughts myself okay well
first of all the book's called worthy it
could easily be called the masculation a
Will Smith story like how like first and
foremost Pat Jada she could do whatever
she wants you could party you could hook
up with all your friends 19-year-old
your son's uh friends you could do like
why do you have to put it out in the
public like and I get it pat she's
selling a book it's almost like Colin
Kaepernick when he had his book coming
out guess what he said hey everybody's
racist even my white parents who adopted
me like it's it's a trend when somebody
wants the eyeballs but it and it's a fun
not a fun fact but the fact that you
know when they did the whole Oscar slap
when he was like keep my effing wife's
name out your mouth they weren't married
they weren so when he said wife she was
like he's not talking to me but I it
this this all comes down to have a
complete different Theory but goad okay
complete Theory but and then Pat mind
you she even said like this is all stuff
that you don't say stuff like uh uh
Tupac might soulmate like what like this
is all information that you take to the
Grave to yourself your husb like Will
Smith's Legacy pad his name is no matter
from from now on for the rest of your
life when you look at him are you going
to think of I Am Legend and uh
Independence say no you're thinking
about this embarrassing ass moment and
it's just it's horrible Adam like don't
it's almost like he's the fresh prince
of bald hair anything else let me tell
you what I here's what I got here's what
I got okay so again I like to say what
the difference uh uh possibilities are
of what's going on here okay one I
believe this book was written with that
seven years to publicly save Will Smith
from being humiliated that his wife
hooked up with you know whatever that
August August August Aus whatever the
guy's name is right okay so that's one
so that kind of is like oh so they
weren't together so apparently they
weren't together they were separated
it's not a big deal so you know it's
just kind of what happened it's pretty
embarrassing you know everybody here has
been uh you've either cheated or you've
been cheated on and if you've been on
the cheated on S it's heartbreaking
devastating publicly embarrassing and uh
uh it's not a nice season of your life
when you go through it okay two uh uh
while she's writing this book you know
um marketing scheme okay uh to do that
okay cool three is Will Smith talking
the way he does you ever seen a movie
original sin with Angelina Jolie and
Antonio bandas you ever seen that movie
original s have you seen original holy
fre that's another one I got to watch so
the movie for those of you that have
seen original and comment below if
you've seen it if you know what I'm
talking the story is about the fact that
you know Antonio bondas is this like
Rich successful let me read the uh just
go to the to read like The yeah go to
Wikipedia just kind of give you an idea
what it's about so Antonio Banderas is
in love with her and no matter what she
does to him he cannot let her go okay he
just cannot let her go she's pretty much
destroying him publicly to everybody but
he keeps coming back okay so maybe he's
in love with her like anonio bandas is
in love with Angelina Jolie in original
sin you have to watch it very weird
watch very weird movie number three
number three Maybe Will Smith is being
held hostage okay maybe she has him
hostage because she has Intel on him for
the past 20-some years with things he
likes sexually other men She's Got Dirt
she's got that and so Will Smith's like
dude I am so in jail and nobody knows it
good point and because I'm in jail I
have to say all of this stuff because
God forbid if I don't she is do you
believe she's the type of a person that
could come out and become Amber Her 2.0
and want to destroy Will Smith's life do
you believe she could do that 100% I
don't put a pass on now here's the thing
you have to realize that most you know
how everybody uh the other day uh we had
the the uh uh um Tommy Mata and Thalia
they came into the building and we
having a meeting together and Leo's like
oh my he's in the middle of a calling a
zo drops the zoom runs up to her it's
like oh my godia and then Clarissa text
me saying you know that was his that was
his love of his life when he was younger
teenager cuz Talia was like the girl wow
so anyways to me it was Jada pingit okay
I watched Jason's Lyric and I was in
love okay this was my girl I can tell
you the playlist of you know uh Jason's
Lyric from you know if You Think You're
Lonely Now wait until tonight you know
that was the the song in that soundtrack
does another one many rivers to cross
beautiful song it's a great soundtrack I
would play on repeat regularly I was in
love with Jada Jada was my girl at 18
years old this is going to be the girl
I'm going to be with okay well thank God
will got her instead of I'm thankful for
will but anyways this was somebody that
I loved her movies the stuff she was set
it off she was in all these different
scenes and I'm a Tupac guy so there's an
element there as well but for me um I
think it's embarrassing I feel bad for
Will Smith I feel bad for what's going
on um I I feel embarrassed for the way
this is being handled there's a lot of
things you should do to sell books if
you're going to be advertising the
person you're still married to and
advertise all his business all your
business publicly it's it's it's not my
style I I'm not turned on by that kind
of a thing it is a modern-day thing that
a lot of people do but I think Will
Smith is in jail and I think Will Smith
needs to go have dinner with Johnny Deb
and hang out with him for a weekend
somewhere in France and have some wine
together enjoy maybe he can have Mero
with Johnny Depp and talk about's
although I don't think Johnny Depp
drinks Merlo no yeah so we're not
drinking Mero I know you've talked about
from the movie your relationship or you
know with with Jada I have a question
for Vinnie so it sounds like you you
almost think that so have you ever been
in love of course you have yeah what
happened happened I was in the
military I was young I made mistakes I
cheated I was an idiot so how long ago
was that in love
Yeah six years ago okay so it's been
it's been quite some time so remember
the time we loved we said love made
um so it so you're basically saying that
you think that Will's almost a victim in
this situation of course cuz she's
putting him his his information out
there and they have kids and so but
why didn't he just officially leave her
then Adam cuz we're like what and again
you you you always think that you're the
relationship Guru and it's I'm
sorry like now oh now when's the last
time you were in love I love how you
trying to change love right now this is
no this is cuz I'm just I'm
posing a question I'm not I'm not trying
no you are trying to attack CU you think
you're talking and it's
and it's stupid like what cuz I haven't
been in love when's the last time you
were in love I'm currently in love love
well Adam really Vinnie I ask I as
you a simple
question it almost sounds like you're
like defending Will Smith he has no
autonomy or authority over his own life
and he's just victim and say you giving
me advice about relationships is
probably the funniest I've ever
heard maybe maybe maybe 45 years old
maybe you should use some advice
for 43 and you're single too no
not single anymore guys were you
divorced yeah I was all right so H Pat
are you giving me I'm just
saying that like Adam you're stupid who
are you to just talk about your
color you're showing your true colors at
him you should be embarrassed
with yourself seriously how are you
going to talk Will Smith has looks like
a cuck he looks stupid you look stupid
you look really D because I'm saying
that will has the ability to make his
own decisions and he decides toay with
you're you're you're dumb as you're
talking what is me having to be in
love and whatever I I'm I'm looking for
the right one you know Vinnie I always
defend you people Adam Adam Vinnie I
always defend you like you feel like I'm
being an antagonist right now I ask a
simple question it's a simple question
but I but I know who you are as a person
and I know who you are Vinnie I see what
the people say behind your back all the
time if we go in the chat right now
they're all talking about you hold
on P I love you but Adam you Adam
it's bro it's BS okay yeah right yeah
you what what then go let's go outside
then if you're going to be that guy I'm
not going to go outside you want me to
you want you want to meet me there after
the podcast how about this I'll
I'll I'll walk off the podcast right now
when you walk out there I'll be waiting
for you all right cool want to play that
game let play that game like the chat
isn't talking about you like the
chat isn't talking about him right
now Pat is the chat talking about
him Pat is the chat is the chat talking
about Adam Adam if anybody wants to
talk about mortgage rates I'm over here
the hell with the mortgage rate what
it's one more thing what what
one more
thing happy birthday to
you happy birth are good to you that was
my gift that was a show that was a show
best birthday present I love a good
fight I love a good fight that was a
sick fight
huh
the
camera
the dud that was sick that was great I'm
like I'm entertained I'm letting this to
go that I got a dream call you want to
go now bro you want to go B hey guys was
that believe was that believable that
was sick by that was that was good I saw
the door open up I'm seeing Kelly I'm
like I see what's going on here I was
impressed this was very good did you
believe it thank you so much guys did
you believe that and I here's what
matters the audience believed
it wait I'm over here I'm trying to go
in I'm like I got to talk I got to talk
a lot but but Pat can I say one
thing CU I have to write it down because
I I have to so much to memorize but Pat
you're not just a CEO you're a friend
you're a mentor you're an amazing father
you're a great husband you're a great
son to Gabriel your guidance inspiration
leadership has set a bar for all of us
for excellence you challenge everybody
every day uh in our life to be better
versions of ourselves including me
you've changed my life tremendously uh
you've shown us what it means to be to
lead in both vision and compassion so
pan day I want to wish you a happy
birthday filled with love continued
success and may your journey ahead be as
bright bright as your path that you've
illuminated for all of us I love you my
man love you
[Applause]
bro I I almost did want to punch Adam in
the Facebook I I will still meet you
outside the last time you love shut
up yeah I we so I I don't have an
eloquent speech as as Vinnie did I had
to like Vinnie's a professional comedian
actor I actually had to get into the
moment and just like focus on that but
Vinnie well done that we had this sort
of planned but just to kind of echo what
Vinnie's saying pbd uh you know how much
people respect you and love you and I
know you don't like compliments but just
know that we're all with you we're
riding with you we're not going anywhere
we love you brother Mentor father son
you do so much for us thank you for
leading us my man made fut continue like
and Gabriel thank you for having him cuz
the world is a better place with you in
it what a freaking May what I'd like to
you Tom stay out of this buddy this is
between and I you want to go Tom keep
your mortgage rate and shove them up
your ass
Tom did you even go to freaking Medical
School bis what are you the doctor of
doctor of what pouring out k take Tarts
and shove them up your ass just kidding
Tom we love you we love you wow yeah boy
that went crazy you know in a day we
I'll I'll finish with this in a day
where we're in here covering conflict
and a world that's really than everybody
thanks babe yeah you know what Mario
you're looking thick Jamar you look sexy
dude but wa Tom cuz don't lose your
don't lose your message Tom cuz I want
to
hear no I think on a on a day most
people don't see on a day when there's
so much conflict in the world and
there's so much bad news that we're
covering you know if you understood the
team atmosphere and everything what we
built here and I say thank you Pat for
allowing me to be a part of it you know
thank you for bringing me to PHP when
you did and thank you for taking me on
the next ride because I've loved every
bit of it and I just say happy birthday
thank you for being my friend I am just
thrilled to be here and again when
there's so much conflict in the world
we're coming together with a real
purpose and everything I thank you for
being part of that purp and taking us on
this ride appreciate you guys appreciate
you guys there's nothing like working
with people that you love to come work
with that work doesn't feel like work
it's just I'm having a blast with the
people that we're spending time with
future looks bright uh uh what a weird
set of ways you guys wish me a happy
birthday but this goes down as one of
the best was it good we got 50,000
people watching live I think they wanted
to see us fight oh they do and by the
way we ran a poll 82% think Vinnie would
win in a fight you
let's go bro you want to go they don't
realize I'm 6' 200 you're 5' 100 they
don't know
that ABS don't help fight buddy all
right Gang This was great thank you so
much everybody thank you for all the
best wishes here uh we will do this
again Rob are we doing it Thursday
Thursday Thursday again thanks everybody
take care bye- bye
bye-bye